What's up everyone? Today we're learning English
with the incredible Disney animation Moana.
In this lesson you'll have a lot
of fun learning English with Moana
and the character Maui,
which is voiced by The Rock.
In case you're new here, I want to let you
know that every week we make lessons to help
you learn fast English. Without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and without subtitles.
In fact, Della says that our lessons
are interesting and understandable,
without being boring. So if that sounds good
to you don't forget to hit that Subscribe
button and the Bell down below, so that
you don't miss any of our new lessons.
We are very close to reaching 3 Million
subscribers here on Learn English with TV.
And so to thank you we are holding a very
special contest over on our Instagram page,
where you can win our Fluent with Friends course.
In this 48-week course you will learn with the
first two seasons of Friends. You'll receive pdf
power lessons every week, vocabulary memorization
software, access to our Fluency Circle Global
Community, and so much more! If you head over
to our Instagram @reallife.english you will find
all the information there, so that you can enter,
and I will be going live next week to
announce the competition winners. Good luck!
If you're enjoying this lesson, then I highly
recommend that you check out our lesson
with the incredible animation Inside Out, where
you can learn vocabulary related to emotions.
So you can click up here or in the description
box below to watch that lesson next.